Cómo cambia la naturaleza de la
institución policial
Muchas gracias por la oportunidad de
explicar esta grave situación lo que
esta propuesta de reforma constitucional
y de la ley de la policía hace es
formalizar jurídica y
constitucionalmente lo que en la
práctica ha sucedido que es la
destrucción de la subordinación civil de
la policía y ponerla totalmente bajo el
control político partidario del frente
sandinista en el carácter de Daniel
Ortega que se presenta a sí mismo no
solo como jefe de estado sino como el
jefe de un partido hegemónico recordemos
que la policía se llamaba policía
sandinista en la transición democrática
se construyó un modelo de policía civil
con elementos de la Democracia
occidental lo que hace esta reforma es
asemejar a la policía de forma jurídica
a lo que existe por ejemplo en países
como Cuba o como China
ahora la propuesta ofrece como
adelantábamos también cárcel a quienes
son considerados por el gobierno
oficiales desertores y desobedientes
Estas son las palabras textuales existe
una oposición Ortega dentro de la fuerza
policial Cómo es su vínculo con estas
fuerzas cuyo apoyo es clave verdad
efectivamente la reforma establece tres
sanciones adicionales al a cualquier
oficial que desobedezca las leyes
prácticamente invisibiliza el control
civil democrático resta por completo
cualquier rol parlamentario y lo que
claramente indica esta reforma es que
Daniel Ortega y la ilegítima
vicepresidenta de Nicaragua Rosario
Murillo tienen mucho temor que dentro de
la policía pueda haber una eventual y
subordinación lo que sí se ha
documentado es un número importante de
policías particularmente de bajo Rango
que han salido de la fuerza policial y
algunos de ellos Incluso se encuentran
ya en Estados Unidos por qué cree que
llega a esta medida en este momento en
particular Bueno usted nos decía que
están intentando contener no a quienes
consideran subversivos
el régimen de Ortega ha decidido
radicalizarse ha iniciado un proceso de
cercanía con china con irán con Rusia
Además de eso una persecución a la
iglesia católica nicaragüense y esto le
ha generado elementos de descontento
dentro de su propia base el régimen de
Ortega quiere asegurarse que tanto la
policía como el ejército no le causarían
problemas en una eventual y
subordinación quiere controlarlo todo